[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I nearly forgot to write this then let
the city look reading went out
[Laughter]
hello and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel and we are
going to have I can give a rant but I'll
introduce you in a second shut up
Matthew wait your turn
um I'm gonna have a bit of a rant
tonight in this Star Gate related so
we'll get into it in a second and no
shock if you've been watching the news
it's going to be giant freaking robot
but Matt how are you sir you're allowed
to speak now I'm good I'm good how are
you very awesome a bit irritated I know
I'm slightly annoyed but uh
we'll get into it so this week
giant freaking robot
right now
the initial story
that
um there's gonna be a movie there's
going to be a movie in Kurt Russell and
James Spade it could be in it and
initially when I read it I went nah what
a load of rubbish you can see my video
on Sidetrack sides
I then actually spoke to a couple of the
people I speak to about this and
actually it's turned out it might have a
nugget of truth to it but I'll explain
why I actually think that this line
they're making [ __ ] up and I've just got
a little bit lucky
um in a second but it actually turns out
Kurt Russell has it it is possible that
if they were to do a reboot movie that
they would like Kurt Russell to appear
in it
um but
the very very simple truth good evening
Shelley how are you the runner of our
Facebook page and and generally just
awesome person and she's Canadian here
so um she's just lovely I call Canadians
I hope she's Canadian I've actually
lives in Canada oh anyway
I got off topic so giant freaking robot
they did a story saying that Kurt
Russell and James Spader are coming back
it's going to be a sequel I said at the
time this this story goes back from a
story from 2015 when this was actually
proposed and the MGM went as far as
green light in it but then it got
scrapped
but it is true and I've known and I've
been saying over and over again for the
last 12 months ideally Amazon would like
to do a movie first they would like to
do a big Blockbuster a boom straight to
Amazon movie and then follow up with the
TV series
but anyway you saw the story what do you
think about the the original story and
then we're gonna go into the other two
let me know I'm going to be speaking
about you in a little while sir hello
the original story being that they're
going to be making a movie yeah
I'm doing a movie a sequel that's
important they're going to be a sequel
to the original Stargate movie
I have always wanted to see the trilogy
because I back in what was it like 2015
when the green light originally yeah
2015. yeah I re I was quite excited for
that I was quite because I wanted to see
where uh Emerick and and that lot
um
originally visioned it to go yeah I kind
of had uh we got
um kind of like a synopsis where it was
going to go to like a Mayan kind of
planet for the second movie and then the
third one was going to be something that
ties it all together and we can discover
our Origins as a species kind of thing I
kind of like that idea and I really
wanted to see it
however
if they do make a movie
is gonna
um
it's going to face over Canon
see the thing is if they do a sequel
movie right because the series was based
on the movie right so the changing
actors it's not the end of the world
Richard Dean Anderson for me is Colonel
O'Neal but so is Kurt Russell so if if
Kurt Russell came back as supposedly an
older character or they just wanted to
bring Colonel O'Neill back in and
Richard nanson didn't want to do it and
let's be honest he didn't want to do
Stargate towards the end so maybe he
doesn't he's got lots of other projects
he's involved in he's a big
environmentalist and stuff so maybe just
wonder so if they were to do if they
want to just bring Kurt Russell in as
Jack O'Neill for a new project a new
movie following on from the series I I
think that could work and I don't I I
you can ignore it because it's still the
original actor why not
um particularly if RDA doesn't want to
do it
but the thing is if they do a sequel to
the original movie it's got to be
um they've got to ignore Stargate sg1 SG
universe and SG Atlantis they've got to
because too much has gone on
yeah there's there's too much it can't
be a sequel to the original film
it they could do a film that's a
continuation right a new film where
everything happened but if they do a
sequel to the original film which is
what giant freaking robot are talking
about and what they were talking about
back in 2015 it's got to be
it's got to be a hard reboot base
basically even though you're obviously
keeping the original films on the top
but you've got to ignore the series
you've got to
yeah you might see my fear with that is
if they do go in that direction and then
if a TV show gets greenlit as well
they'll essentially be doing what Disney
did with Star Wars and decanonizing
everything that that came before like
Star Wars Legends for example everything
that there was there was
thousands of books
written and loads of stories but they're
all now Legends they're not
um Canon I wouldn't want that for this
series
but if they did a movie
I would accept it if it was if it was
um
positioned as this is
not the same universe as uh SG-1
Atlantis and universe inhabits it's a
different Universe [ __ ] yeah oh man I
hate that and Alexa anybody that's
regular to the little nose I hate that I
think I think it's so lazy
um either do a hard reboot or don't you
know and I I I've got nothing wrong
against a hard reboot they're talking
about doing a hard reboot of the
Highlander movie and I'm like like yeah
I want to see that the original
Highlander great story but they they
ruined it with the TV series and
everything so I'm just like yeah start
again be brilliant
I can see the argument for doing a hard
reboot of Stargate because I can't quite
see how it's going to work because we
got so Advanced towards the end
now we got so I mean what's the what's
the villain gonna be have to be to be
actually to be a threat to us because
we're so Advanced by the end you know
and it's got to be
the the human species I I did a video
and I basically said we want Stargate
not Star Trek because towards the end of
Stargate
um it was becoming a space I've got a
full-on Sci-Fi that's not what Stargate
was was it it was always supposed to be
like this could happen this could be
real this could be going on right now is
going to planets with the technology we
have right now
yeah exactly yeah but Roland Emerick in
an interview about six months ago did
say he'd spoke to Amazon and they were
talking about this idea again
right
um and uh we spoke to MGM sorry they
were talking it was just before the sale
went through and but he said he got the
distinct impression that they were only
interested in the TV audience they
weren't interested in the movie audience
so he says he does not want to do it he
didn't want to do Stargate
um he did set the time if they do a
movie he might have to be involved
because he's contracted to it and I've
already found out since that's not
necessarily true if Amazon do a direct
to Amazon Prime movie because it's not a
cinematic release so it wouldn't be
contractually obliged to get involved
um
but
you know that's
sorry I lost my truck I've lost my train
of thought off for three lessons life is
such a pain in the neck of just lose a
train thought
um
but he basically said now it's not he's
not interested and for me if they're
talking about the TV audience is more
important they're talking about sg1 SG
and SGA and that's what people love and
I think most Gators will say the film
was good
but
the series is what we love yeah
but from a financial point of view
Amazon if somebody that doesn't really
care about this looks at the numbers
Stargate is the 10th highest grosser
movie of all time for MGM
yeah
but
the reason every people want the show is
because the show expanded on the movie
um if they try to make lightning strike
twice by making a hard reboot in the
movie it's not gonna it's not gonna do
as well as
it did originally because I didn't
expect it to do well the first time and
now if they do it again and they expect
it to do well it's not it's not going to
happen
well the thing was I mean it was
actually produced by another production
company it wasn't MGM and this company
was so convinced it was going to bomb
they sold it to MGM for like I think it
was like 15 million dollars or something
silly it was nothing and then it went on
to gross over 200 million dollars so I
mean it was um at the box office so I
mean it was like back then I mean and
we're talking about 30 years ago uh 27
years ago so I mean it's you know it did
phenomenally well for them and obviously
then spawned three television series
which are again were phenomenally
popular
so it's the second you've got to
remember as well this is the second most
valuable franchise behind bond for MGM
you know if you're talking purely money
sort of thing so coaches again
so one thing I'm going to say to you
right now as well but for everybody and
thing you know we've got a big we want
Stargate
um next week and why am I we start
getting his T-shirt it's available at
sideastric.com there's other brilliant I
love my have you seen my design for the
um it's the Stargate with a golf swing
I'm really quite proud of that design
um so nice and simple as well but anyway
um
so we've got this we're going to do a
Twitter campaign I'm going to talk about
the Twitter
um
hooplar in a minute but we've got this
Twitter campaign we want to really shove
it down because it's 25th anniversary of
sg1 first appearing on RTD screens
so next week we're going to really think
that's the reason why we're doing this
video today because it's a week to go
and we want to really push it
um
it's the second highest most valuable
franchise so I'm going to reassure
everybody now the as Amazon wants to do
Stargate it's as simple as that they are
desperate to do star game the problem is
they don't know how they don't know what
to do with it and that's why giant
freaking robot is a flipping liar right
they do not have anything what they have
seen
is they've seen that Stargate was
trending
on Twitter because of Us slot because we
all have been going on to it and I'd say
there's some brilliant campaigns which
games I'll talk about in a minute some
brilliant campaigns on on Twitter
but they've seen that it's trending
pulled a story out of their ass inspired
by something happened seven years ago
and they might have sources in and
around these people so they might have
heard about the Kurt Russell thing but I
doubt it
and then they've released the story
saying there's going to be a sequel
movie which
to be honest I'm very worried about
might actually be true but I don't think
Amazon is stupid enough to do that
so
that's the problem Amazon have for that
right this is why Stargate is taking so
long because Amazon are between a rock
and a hard place the easy thing to do is
a reboot the easy thing to do is do a
sequel to the original movie but they
know the fans will go crazy
so they can't so they don't know what to
do with it
they've got brand right script but I've
been telling you guys for nine months
they don't like it
so they don't know what to do with it
they they they literally have no idea
and you're gonna remember this is 100 to
150 million dollars investment Amazon
are gonna make if they decide to make a
series so 10 even 10 episode series
you know it's a lot of money they have
to invest for something they're just
they're just they're just not sure but
yeah
giant freaking robot talking absolute
crap but then
they went on
so they've released two more stories
since because that story got a lot of
clicks
so then they released a story
taking credit for the hashtag we want
Stargate
saying look look at since we put this
story out it started trending and we
want Stargate started trending
um aren't we brilliant let's bring back
Stargate everyone they took [ __ ]
credit for it it was trending the day
before they posted their original
article
Sebastian here oh let me have I'm sorry
I'm sorry saying this so badly mad
medieval I don't know I'm not going to
speak French I apologize Sebastian but
Sebastian has been talking about this
for three months he's been trying to get
this to people to push this on the 25th
um I'm going to talk about the crappies
that to put up with in a minute but
um
you know so he's been told me someone's
I've been talking about this chance so
by giant freaks I I put a thing on
Facebook saying basically buy giant
freaking robots logic
um I think I am responsible I think I
deserve the credit
because I've been talking about this for
nine months I've been telling everybody
that they want to do a movie
um I actually did hear about Kurt
Russell maybe coming back a couple of
months ago but I thought I don't believe
I was there's only one person that told
me so I didn't believe it so I didn't
share it with anyone I was like I'm not
I'm not touching that I'm going to get
I'll have the pistol Academy if I say so
then I can't back it up at all so
um but um you know so I actually think I
deserve the credit but actually the
people that do deserve the credit are
the people like Sebastian that are
killing it on on you Twitter the people
that are doing things like the 365 days
of Stargate and I've actually gone on
there every single day with these
hashtags and done little things and you
know and and 100 other people that have
been killing themselves to because they
desperately want the showback because
they deserve the credit and giant
freaking robot are coming into a
newspaper article saying how brilliant
they are toss us yeah say the gate's
been going for
years yeah I don't know I think I think
that might have been the podcast you
started that one
um
they've been very involved they're one
of the few people that actually
responded to Sebastian when he first
started trying to share this they
actually did come back through I'm not
always pop cast's biggest fan I think
they click about it a little bit and
with some of their stories and I really
don't like how they put videos together
that take 20 minutes to get to the point
um but they do work really hard and they
they like yeah like you said they've
been involved in this for years yeah and
so give them respect you know that
they're due and they did respond to
Sebastian they did share his his story
out you know they did they did trying
they have to back them up
well in terms of the community they're
probably
people will probably recognize them more
uh as one of the biggest
contributors for trying to save the gate
they're trying to stay Stargate because
they had they had their initial success
I believe when they've done their
definitive history of Stargate yeah that
video has got like I think it's close to
I think it's over a million views yeah I
don't surprise me as well they do good
videos yeah everything from then they
obviously made loads more Slugger
content but then they started the
campaign
and yeah it's it's not it's not it's
obviously not just them there's loads of
people
I have been tweeting for years that we
once targeted back I've never started a
campaign but just me individually with a
credit too I know
when you posted that on your channel I
left a comment go I've just I've just uh
posted on Facebook that the the there's
a heat wave and funnily enough it's
trending coincidence I think no exactly
you you you were to blame for the
Heatwave I just saw it I'm gonna slap
you on your ball dead I was a nightmare
yesterday
yeah I'm still a little climb it's still
quite humid here
um
but yeah so but then they've released a
story yesterday now saying that Chris
Hemsworth's brother Liam is being tapped
up to
um do the movie I assume with Kurt
Russell
um and again
hey it's logical this is an actor that's
worked with Roland Emrick before he's an
actor actually that quite likes to
produce an executive producer's own
stuff
um he's one of those actors sort of
thing that gets really likes to really
get involved in the story if they could
get somebody like that on board he's got
a big name he's not a particularly big
actor himself but he's got a big name
completely logical
but it's not true
um because like I've said to repeat
Stargate don't know what they're doing
with this so why do you think they're
tapping up actors if they haven't got a
script or even though technically they
have got a script for the sequel they've
had a script for this potentially for
years I imagine they would have to dust
it off and rework it a little bit but
they've had a script for this for a long
time but um but they wouldn't be talking
tractors yet
it's it's way too early we would know
um more about what was going on if they
were starting to talk practice
and I have a theory about it about where
they pulled the name out from
Liam was in Independence Day the
Independence Day uh Resurgence I think
yeah yeah
which is a project by Dean Devlin Ronan
Emerick obviously
they they did Stargate
then they went on to do Independence Day
so for a giant physical robot probably
looking at actors that they've worked
with
like recently because I mean it was 2015
2016 when that movie came out
um so it's quite recent yeah and they're
probably just look at looking through
and going well that could work that
could work that could work and there's
picking names and throwing them out
there I'm hoping one of them sticks
because yeah it probably would stick if
you do it enough times
they're a chimpanzee throwing [ __ ] out
of her out of their cage and just hoping
and they know that some of it will hit
something and that sort of thing is and
that's why they're doing but they've
done three stories they haven't talked
about Stargate in nearly a year and then
they've done three stories in three days
yeah let's get this trending on Twitter
that's the simple that's it that is it
um
I hope we learned something that's
standing in Comic Con this weekend but I
don't think we will
um from what I mean right so again just
to just to be really clear about where
we're at with Stargate right now and
this could change
um and also I mean I did the speed
people I speak to I keep trying to
reinforce this because I keep that's
just something I keep getting accused of
being a clickbaiter and and talking
rubbish myself all I can do is share
what I'm told
um
and keep repeating the fact that these
are not top Executives I talk to but
they do work in and around MGM one or
two of them have got a little bit more
access than others
in certain areas
so when I talk about legal stuff I can I
I've got a little bit more confidence in
what I'm talking about and some of them
uh are just people that work in a
building you know they're not they're
not they're nothing but it's a bit of a
network I built up
so I'm going to tell you what I'm told
and I'll do my best with it
I would argue that if they were going to
go with Brad Wright they'd have green
lifted by name and the longer it goes I
think the more credibility what I've
been telling you should have because I'm
telling you why and I've been telling
you why it's it's slow for ages
um
so yeah people want to call me call me
say I'm basically a liar then to say
Well we'd have had Stargate now
you know they've got a script Brad
Wright's ready to go
why haven't we
you know let's go
um
so that annoys me a little bit I
um also I could talk rubbish and I could
do big like rare stories and just hope
nobody remembers but I don't I keep
telling you when stuff's a rumor when
it's not but anyway let's try to be
honest but anyway
so um
that's it again I'm ranting I keep
forgetting my ways
what I was going to say actually was uh
I think it was Chris Smith a little
while ago I had a really good point that
they'll try to do like a hybrid of the
two I think what Amazon are going to do
is they'll Star Trek this
and they'll new track it
so they will I think they could do a
movie I think Kurt Russell appearing in
it is very possible
and they won't worry too much about that
and they will pick and choose the Canon
from the TV series that makes sense they
won't worry about it too much they'll
clear a new story but ever so often
they'll pick something from the TV
series
to sort of go oh remember this or
remember that so they'll they'll they
won't worry too much about Canon the
stores will just develop but then
they'll try to keep the fans Happy by
you know those little Easter eggs and
things
in the past yeah
that could work so someone
um
that Lee media what is that Sebastian
yeah so he he made a point yeah that the
um
the new show the the new audience might
be slightly larger than the old audience
yeah
and that's something I was thinking
about as well
they are going to be looking at
tapping into
the new generation because
realistically Stargate fans who watched
from the very beginning they've got to
be
30s 40s 50s and older and mid-40s yeah
so I mean I I started watching it when I
was 11 years old and I'm 30 next year so
I'm probably one of the younger fans
obviously streaming services are popular
with the young
things like stranger things and things
like that yeah very popular with the
younger generation very young
demographic yeah they're gonna try
they're gonna try to
tailor to them I think
more so but
if they do that I wouldn't be
as annoyed if if they do what you've
just said and do little nods to the Past
acknowledge its existence kind of thing
yeah
that wouldn't that wouldn't be too bad
for me
I think long enough is gone remember
it's not been on our screens for 11
years now as well you know
so long enough has gone by
that you're going to be aiming towards a
new
a new audience as well you it's not just
it's not just appeasing us they've got
to do something that's going to try to
bring in like you said those guys that
were only a couple of years old went
a universe ended
yeah
what do you think about the universe
though is it because I I do think this I
know the people that love Stargate
Universe love it and some people think
it's the best of the Stargate three I I
don't
um I think it was a it was it ended on a
bit of a low even though it was getting
better I will I will concede it was
getting better but when it got canceled
I was just like well yeah of course it's
got canceled it's it's it's actually
borderline boring
um I think the right was on the wall
well into very early on in the second
series
um but what do you think how much did
Stargate Universe hurt it or how much
does it because it sort of
ended on a low does it mean that they
doing this like hybrid thing is even
more likely because I can almost pretend
like that didn't happen
um see I've I've oh I'm I'm the opposite
to you I I liked universe and I always
thought it was too ahead of its time
when it come out
the audience just wasn't ready for it
because you look at shows that come out
kind of like now
like the expanse and things like that
they're they're pretty dark they're
pretty character driven much like what
Universe was it wasn't very action based
that's like what the expanse is now if
if Universe came out now it would do
fantastic
um
but yeah I remembering expanse didn't do
fantastic
did it not it did okay
um it never got the numbers Amazon
wanted and that's one of the reasons why
we're in a pause at the moment and I
guess another series they don't quite
know what to do with
um but I think
I I I if we do a slight adjustment to
what you said I think if it came out now
and it was put on
um stream of services it would get a lot
of respect it would win Awards
I don't necessarily think it would get
loads of views
I think it would get good views and I
think it would get a really loyal fan
base
and actually
streaming services aren't as bothered
about like viewing figures as they used
to be they care about the demographic
and they care about loyalty in that if
will they have a show that people will
follow
to their platform
so platform Paramount plus love Star
Trek because suckers like me will get
Paramount plus because they want to
watch Star Trek they won't watch
anything else on the platform
necessarily you know if I find something
else on there that's great but I get
Paramount plus to watch Star Trek yeah
you know
um and that's what Amazon Plus Amazon
Prime want with Stargate because even if
they don't get you know 50 60 million
people watching every week they won't
care because even two or three million
people will subscribe just to watch it
you know and that's what they care about
they get they'll get the growth and
they'll get the thing and the expanse is
the seamless why the expanse will come
back so it's got a hardcore but quite a
small fan base yeah but it will come
back because they're not as bothered
about
the viewer figures as a network used to
be which is advertising is the point
because you have to remember that's
whether it's the difference in where the
revenue comes from isn't it it's not
advertising it's subscriptions so how do
you increase subscriptions
it's almost better to have several
cult shows almost
that people will follow you know and
people will stay online for for the next
season
um you're not you're not abiding to to
um advertisers going I don't like that
show we don't want to advertise on that
show
I said it gets cut
well yeah that's very true and the only
reason I have Disney plus is for the
Star Wars shows I don't watch anything
else on Disney
I I don't want you anymore I like Marvel
but I don't like I If I've watched it
once I'm not gonna watch it again
like I'm not really that bothered about
it Star Wars I will re-watch like the
Mandalorian and Boba Fett and Obi-Wan
and I'm gonna try and get into Clone
Wars as well on uh several people's
recommendations
um and the only reason I have Amazon
Prime
other than the fact I use it for twitch
um is I use it for the boys and now the
expanse
yeah yeah
Disney Star Wars is dead
I think I think that sort of thing isn't
it as well this is another reason why
Amazon are 100 going to make Stargate
though because they won
um
a Sci-Fi franchise look Disney are
killing it with Star Wars
um Paramount are gonna get Star Trek you
know like I mean I know Amazon got
Picard
and got lower decks but they're not
going to be getting anything new
just look how well strange new world is
doing
that's that's the sort of thing that's
what stargate's going to look like and I
I honestly think I I actually got a lot
of [ __ ] um six months ago or so because
I said
star Stargate producers and MGM and
Amazon were saying look at Star Trek
when they for the production value and a
lot of people went I don't want them to
look like new tricks crap I said no
you're missing the point it's the
production value it's the little more
strange new worlds I think strangely
worlds will be what they really look at
now because it's been phenomenal hasn't
it it's been so popular
um it's but easily the best the easily
the most popular Star Trek and of the
new Trek series by by quite a white away
record I reckon so um but it's got a bit
of humor in it it's got actions I think
that's what's a new Star Trek's gonna
look the Stargate story is going to look
like
um if they've got any sense anyway but
it won't look like Stargate Universe
it'll look more like Stargate sg1
but with a much bigger budget
nicer cameras nicer sets a lot more CGI
yeah
it's not necessarily a bad thing in a
Sci-Fi show
yeah
yeah
um one thing I did want it I'm sorry oh
the worry I have
is
if they're trying to go down the same
route as
of the popular
um franchises like Star Wars Star Trek
whatever
um
I don't really want them to have
see I'm going to say this but I I do
want it and I don't
um like loads and loads of different
shows
like I don't want
uh I don't know Stargate Asgard then
Stargate go old and then Stargate the
aurai and then Stargate ancient
the reason I said I'm gonna say I don't
want I want that but I do it's because
of the ancient's prequel I do want that
one I think that's something apparently
they were looking at but this was before
when MGM thought it was going to have
free reign yeah I don't want that to be
like I don't know stock yeah like I say
like multiple different
interconnected like
loads of different shows like Marvel do
and Disney because it's very hard to
keep up
especially on the different time frames
thank you Star Wars you have to do math
every time a new show comes out
where does this fit
um what I was told but this is back when
MGM thought we've got to remember as
well Stargate came that close to getting
into greenlit Brad writes game for that
close to getting greenlit
um when I when they want to say I went
through MGM thought they had free reign
and they were going to agree that was
going to be the first major project to
create greenlit and then Amazon saw the
books and went
this is the worst run company on the
planet nothing you know everything's on
hold
and they're not being allowed that's why
that's another reason why we've got no
Stargate yet because they've Amazon just
went in and went geez this is a state
this is just complete mess
um but yeah it got that close and they
were in early stage development of doing
Stargate ancients which I actually think
was a prequel I would have been on board
with and I hate prequels
um it's the only thing that makes sense
in in terms of another series
because they they are so far removed
from the car the current Canon that you
can do literally anything you want
um so house activities uh Doom Cox
latest video they're improving there's
an original favorite maybe underwater
it's done follow me his animated side
okay
um I think that's about um Mandalorian
and what I was told while Stargate was
going to do go along the lines of more
like the Mandalorian the Boba Fett and
that way in that the sea they would do
maybe three or four small series a year
of like 10 episodes that they would all
intertwine with each other but they
might be like slightly different
perspectives to the same story like the
Mandalorian and the Boba Fett and a
couple of his other series that are
coming
are
um not not obviously Obi-Wan Obi-Wan's a
completely Standalone but
um that they'd almost be like chapters
in a book and they decided to interlock
with each other and things but that's
again the problem is this is all what
was was when MGM thought they had with
free reign because they were told Amazon
was just going to be the customer and
MGM we're going to be allowed to push
forward to the projects they wanted to
do
um and Amazon would just basically pay
for them
um but then you know those two those two
Chief Executives left I know I know
Amazon have had a few Financial issues
since and they've massively overspent a
Lord of the Rings which is a bit of a
perfect storm really there's like at the
point of the sale going through all
these things just sort of happened all
at once
Stargate oh sorry um Amazon Prime's
figures dropped
yeah and for um live subscriptions which
is the first time in their history
nothing like what Amazon Netflix has
suffered but it dropped and their sales
through Amazon normal dropped which was
always good because it like quadrupled
during covid so if I thought they were
going to keep those numbers up there
insane
um there's a general cost of living
crisis they overspent on Lord of the
Rings and then a lot of people even
though they've not seen it hate it
already
um it's just a bit of a perfect storm
for Stargate to go against all from the
very least that they're going to want to
push MGM to do a project that's
going to work they're not going to want
MGM to waste any money at all
um
but you know it's like
it's just it's just it's just a mess MGM
and that's the biggest problem we've got
um yeah when
the news come out that they they didn't
like
the state of the company
I initially just thought uh how did you
not know the company was a mess
because it what they filed for
bankruptcy 11 years ago yeah and they've
been
basically cleaning up Clinging On with
well probably just James Bond I guess
there are a lot of reality TV shows and
things like that that they own yeah they
owned a lot of little things as well
that they were steadily selling off yeah
so they sold all their
they didn't have Studios did they they
don't have any physical Studios but they
did have
um or at least part of lots of little
channels they had if you have a look at
the what they own it's the list is
massive they had an animation studio
which is where the rumor about them
doing a starter animation series came
from but they got rid of that
um they were they were streamlining
their business over the last 10 years
anyway but that way and actually but I
should say as a business apparently the
last 10 years or so it's been it's been
run quite well and it has been
reasonably profitable I'm talking about
on the creative side of things when they
because that's the sort of thing they
can look at the business books
and go okay well there's this profit
here and they've got this is but when
they actually then like basically
physically went in and got okay what
what where are we at with this project
and there's and apparently the Amazon
Executives were just like why are you
even why are you doing that why are you
going this this is people aren't going
to watch this [ __ ] and and they were
just really annoyed with the the
planning parts of it
um
yeah it always helps me kind of like a
cop-out excuse well I think there's an
element of that as well to be honest
they went in and they they said that
just so they can I don't know Turf
people out do whatever they wanted the
company completely
you can remember as well the sale to MGM
wasn't I mean it wasn't popular so
Amazon was saying all the right things
they were keeping all the MGM people on
side they were saying you're going to
have complete creative control you're
going to be up to this you're going to
do that and then as soon as they
actually got their self went through
they went oh covered
we can't we can't do that because it
covered so only enough financial squeeze
and I'm like whoa whoa whoa you knew
that before the sale you knew that a
year ago yeah we all knew there was
going to be a cost of living crisis we
all you if if you didn't you're an idiot
that there was going to be a financial
or economic impact to two years of
covert so that the economy was going to
be trashed so I mean they knew they knew
that they just were saying the right
things because they weren't they were
trying to get it through the FTC as
smoothly as possible
and they did it worked
yeah really so
um I think Brad Wright is known about
this for a long time as well because I
think that's one of the reasons why he
talks on
um companions so much about Stargate I
think that's why Joseph malozi a couple
who's had tweeted the front page of his
of the script and things like he's been
doing a
um a campaign you know a media campaign
for 12 months because he knows he might
not get to make his show
he's been doing
um
and it an ongoing interview I think I
think they obviously I think they've
what they've do it they do it weekly I
think they get together him and David
Reed uh talking about all the things
that basically reminiscing about the
show and then he's also telling us
little bits uh that we wouldn't uh
otherwise have known such as uh the
things that he tweeted about Atlanta
it's like the potential sixth season he
talks about that as well Joseph malozi
did the same sorry are you talking about
Justice milosi sorry does that doesn't
he
and Brad Rogers and companion and does
that a lot doesn't he yeah on gate world
yeah yeah constantly though absolutely
constantly yeah
[Music]
um
oh you're very welcome sir
um
see me moving again
he gave me a hug I'm gonna give him a
heart yeah why not big cuddles big
cuddles
um let's just have a look make sure
we've copied everything I wanted to talk
about all right so the Twitter storm
isn't a Twitter storm anymore it's a
Twitter event
Sebastian said that I'm doing this
Twitter storm next next week
dag we want Stargate we're all going to
kick off at nine o'clock and we're just
going to go crazy
um first of all a bunch of gators
got upset because they he felt like he
hadn't they hadn't invited him they he
hadn't invited them and I'm just like oh
grow up he's he was he was telling
everybody he could think of only a
couple of people responded to be fair
Joseph malozi responded a pop cast
responded I did and did a video on it
straight away and I thought it was a
great idea
I know they do this or to have different
events every year
and but a lot of them were quite
unpleasant to Sebastian which is really
disappointing
um a couple of others seemed very big of
themselves they thought
no if we're not doing it no one should
it's been moaned up for the hashtag
because he said oh really you you you
have to have the one guy um emailed him
and said you need to do a new hashtag
I've spoken to Joseph malozi and other
Gators and it needs to be specific to
the Twitter store you can't use another
one it's got to be a new one but it
wasn't
I just passed you and I don't know if
you know this but it'll work it would be
better if we did it this way and this
was only a week ago as well the last
couple of days it wasn't that it was
like you need to do a new track and I'm
just like
that's got that's just not that's not
very pleasant to be honest yeah
um the same same chap has texted me and
say oh we're going to have a new hashtag
and I'm just like okay whatever
um so I'll I'll push it next week but
I'm not really I'll push we want
Stargate as well or just Brad Stargate
or whatever you want to whatever you
want to push just let's get on there and
just make as much noise about Stargate
as you possibly can why does it matter
what hashtag you use I mean if if we're
using we want Stargate they're using I
don't know save the game
if they both Trend we all win yeah so
what's the problem
yeah well I need to go manage to Twitter
storms yeah there are rules to it
apparently they was going to text him
the rules and was like what
I mean
I mean it's just like yeah uh make me so
that's my attitude but I'm a bit I'm a
bit of an ass when people tell me what
to do I sort of like go you reckon
um but I thought I can be a bit of a
yeah
if you go to twitter.com twitterstorm
rules it's there oh well there you go
then so who knew
who cared I didn't so I'm just I just
want I just thought you know what what
we should be doing is motivating a fan
base people that adore the show to get
excited about it we should be able to
say we should be saying that's a great
idea Sebastian but if they'd have gone
all but you've also you've never done
this before Sebastian gonna say he's
never done this before he doesn't really
know what he's doing
um or if we do it this way it'll be
better not
why haven't you invited us this isn't
you know like and then are you well you
need to change it anyway you're not
doing it right and quite quite
unpleasantly I was a bit disappointed in
our fan base I was a bit disappointed in
our community really but then there are
but there are people on Twitter like 365
days of star getting a bunch of others
there's too many to say that I do it
that I've really got really behind me
I'll agree to come on here let's do this
and you know I think
I just thought you know what we should
be wanting because
one voice is louder than you know
several disparate voices and there are
other projects going on there are like
the um Stargate video that they want to
put together a fan video and which is I
say go on Twitter you'll find out
there's there's several places sharing
it
um
that's a great idea but you know it's
like us coming on here and talking about
it you know it's just it's it's
kind of interest and interesting you
know let's Build It Up
the negativity is just not necessary
and I would I would argue
um that
we want Stargate more Stargate bring
back Stargate revive Stargate whatever
else this is the wrong campaign really
oh I just hashtag it's the wrong
campaign in a way
if you want Brad Wright to be in charge
it should be
Brad Stargate we want Brad Stargate
because at the way we're going at the
moment it won't be
unless we make a crapload of noise
um and I and I know I don't always get I
get a bit of grief for saying that
because it's not popular and a lot of
people don't want to hear it but
it's the truth we're on they could have
done and I've said this earlier but I
will repeat it we we could have Stargate
greenlit right now we've got a pilot
they've I I know for a fact they did
loads of preliminary work under MGM um
uh initial artwork and things stuff that
they were selling it because they had
two competing scripts at one point
um and Brad's writes won back again when
MGM thought it had full control
um they decided they were going to go
with Branch they did loads of including
budgetary work they did loads of this
work
um I'm not allowed to say this but yeah
I've actually seen some of the budgetary
work so I know for a fact it's true
um
it could be greenlit a lot of the the
groundwork was laid the reason why we're
three or four months on it still hasn't
been is because they're not sure about
Brad's project and that's just that
that's it in a nutshell you know um
yeah
um
I've I've never got a name on it
um one suggestion was that it was Dean
devlin's
but I can't confirm that but that was
the rumor that I was told that it was
it was um yeah it was Joseph it was a
Dean Devlin
and that would have been yeah the
Anunnaki would have been the bad guy
which is uh thank you very much how's
the tradies
I appreciate it sir my coffee fund it's
the wife will let me
keep doing this fund
uh yeah we want Brad's Stargate that
should be the campaign if that's what
you want a continuation the story and
not a reboot
okay
I see Brad gate oh man you should have
come up with that six months ago I think
Brad gate trying to create a Twitter
account right now
um and Sebastian just make a good point
as well I do think one of the reasons
was that Brad Wright wrote a script
based on mgm's capability at the time
three years ago more than three years
ago
and Amazon kept saying we want something
bigger we want something bolder
but since then I've actually been told
Amazon was secretly involved in this
four years ago three and a half years
ago they approached MGM to say we would
love to have Stargate if you make
Stargate we will buy it
you know so I mean it's and when they
were doing the preliminary work and Brad
was doing initial uh writing and doing
rewrites Amazon were actually even
involved at that point saying bigger
bigger bigger sort of thing
um well yeah
what do we think about the AI Scripts
I thought they're a lot of fun
I thought they're a great way of
advertising Stargate again
and I loved seeing RDA and everybody on
this on the big screen
what do you think
I didn't see him I didn't see him
they're on the companion aren't they you
have to pay for it
um
[Laughter]
I've got a lovely subscriber who
assisted me
and seeing it it's a good story that was
good
um I'm going to share a link
okay go for it um but yeah it was good
we want Brad gay we want bad game
and could Brad Wright use these big
finished products so big finish today
have announced that they've actually got
the license back to do podcasts or Well
audio they're not really audio books or
audio stories of original Stargate
series initially we're only going to
actually get the ones they've already
done back on
which apparently you can still get with
a really expensive um but they're going
to be able to re-release those it isn't
actually confirmed whether we're going
to be getting new stories or not just
yet but it looks like hopefully we will
particularly if they're popular
so when they come back out and they
reappear then
um yeah do it
you know
um get in there and uh Twitter we want
Brad Gates send me the link mate we'll
we'll share it later
I've just had two followers I will I
will schedule loads of tweets on this
account okay excellent
um Amazon are making it worse from The
Sounds by dragging their feet down to
continue to lose money I want bright
white star game Amazon should make this
happen or hire a new staff that can
I I do you know I I
if I'm 100 honest
I don't care if they bring back bread
right or not
I I never liked history
I'm just reading this comment Stargate
Wars assemble end game
hashtag
it was a similar again it would Trend so
I could not argue with it I couldn't I
couldn't read the name
yeah
Sam Ismail balsaka soft sequel reboot
yeah
um I've I've heard that they're looking
for a show on well the most recent thing
I've heard now
um but this is a couple of weeks old was
they've put a small team of
um
office people together really
um I imagine there's an office with like
the Stargate logo there's no logo sort
of thing on their own on an office door
there's just just has the home logo sort
of thing
um and that they are trying to put a
list together of who would direct who
would
um think football they are having to do
it for a movie and a TV series but
apparently they still haven't decided
which one to go with but if they were to
go with a project well they want the
movies to immediately feed into a TV
series so the idea being that whoever
runs the movie will go on to do the TV
series a bit like
um gun did with
um after he did
a bloody awful film with
with peacemaking you know and then you
did The Peacemaker TV series about that
James yeah Suicide Squad yeah Suicide
Squad and then go into a new TZ series
that's what they want to do and with
streaming the way they are now they're
like little movies yeah Liam Hemsworth
if he did the movie I could very easily
see him doing a TV series as well I
don't see any reason why it couldn't
breathe through but I don't have to
series now are as big if not bigger than
movies it's not like it was in the old
days where if you did a TV show it was
somehow less than doing a movie
yeah yeah that was very separate wasn't
it yeah the actors TV actors and never
that they you know you didn't you never
crossed over if you remove the actor and
you did a TV show it's because your your
career had gone through the floor
so I think nowadays
you know there's big movies like Chris
Pine and people like this and and um you
know doing a Chris Pratt and whatever
doing doing both you know Chris Evans
even just on a TV series on Amazon Prime
yeah you know it's just like there's no
there's no Stigma to do both at all and
that's that's their thinking so they are
looking at the moment for a showrunner
potentially directors even though I
personally would like Amanda Tapping to
be involved on that side of things and
she has been considered but again that
was back when MGM thought he had control
um I I think Amazon's gonna go a
completely different way with it myself
that's everything I'm hearing
they're gonna go a new Trek way of doing
this
and it's going to be a blended approach
if the if the dice did fall on in our
favor and we we did get Brad back as the
showrunner
it would be fantastic for everyone
because we would like you just said you
want to see Amanda Tapping do some sort
of direct and she would no doubt be
involved because she works with Brad
right now anyway she worked with him on
Travelers
he worked with him back on uh Stargate
as well but
I I want it so bad
I asked the question a little while ago
could Amanda tap in step up and be
showrunner yeah um she's directed for
years and been quite successful she's
been an executive producer as she's
produced and been an executive producer
on a couple of different projects The
Next Step
is potentially show runner and it used
to be traditionally the showrunner
actually wrote like Brad Wright wrote a
lot of the episodes and really guided
the storyline but really like Kevin
Faye's changed that Kevin Faye monitors
and he's a manager over the lot he
doesn't write the stories he doesn't he
monitors the stories and he keeps you
know the ship going in the right
direction Amanda Tapping could do that
if she wanted to I I did wonder about
that a little while ago
um yeah
yeah
I no I don't think MGM did all the
rights of The Hobbit did they um the
family do
they Amazon had to buy the rights for
Lord of the Rings in The Hobbit directly
from the family didn't they from the
tropical estate that's why it costs so
much
because they had to spend like 600
million or something to get the rights
to make the new TV series it's so much
stupid like that
um so now I don't think MGM did hold the
rights to the hospital a million I'm in
the wrong job
um I don't know if they owned
distribution rights
did MGM do the first movies I don't know
but distribution rights and production
rights a lot of the time are
um different
so a company can own the distribution
rights to a project
um let's think of an example
the expanse is a good example the Amazon
owned the distribution rights they don't
actually own the rights to the show a a
separate at the production company does
so Amazon couldn't make the expanse on
their own
um but also the production company can't
make a show and then sell it to whatever
they like because Amazon owned the
distribution rights I just had a quick
look at who
did Lord of the Rings initially it was
new Land Cinema which is a Warner
Brothers company sadly Warner Brothers
so there you go of course it was new
line Cinema
as soon as you say that I can remember
the opening sequence now
um
but yeah I mean so anyway we've got a
week
people
we've got one week to keep shoving
Stargate right up Amazon's backside
with our new hashtag
um bradgate
you see on on the 27th when I tweet I'm
not just going to be using we want
slogan I'm going to use every single
hashtag I can think of yeah and that's
what I'm telling people to do yeah just
hashtag everything
we'll be back on the 27th I don't know
if Matt you can join us or not but I I
will be here at the very least
um and hopefully Matt well anybody else
wants to join us come on we'll have a
bit of a Stargate party
um
sorry I should be able to check with the
missus see what she says oh I made the
decisions
[Laughter]
she doesn't watch the videos no no
oh
shut it Matt
um
but um
uh yeah so we'll be back next week and
seriously if anybody in the chat or is a
regular subscriber Francis join us just
to come on and tell us your thoughts or
your remembrance about Stargate message
me either on here or go to Facebook or
message me
um as long as you don't come on I swear
and stuff I would love to have a few
people on next week let's make let's
have a little bit of a party and I will
put something in the comments and
anybody wants to join what I'm not doing
is doing did you see I don't know if you
would watch me back then I did a video
and I basically invited anyone and I
actually publicly put the link up
uh yeah people joined and then as soon
as I sort of like clicked them on to go
come on say hi
um it's switched to gay porn
oh my God damn it a couple of people did
join though and they were both amazing
aliens in space who's quite is it you
know
you know I think he's he's great you
know he came on he talked to us for
about 20 minutes but but yes if anybody
want to join us and tell us about your
favorite starga episodes or what it
means to you more importantly come and
join us just send me send me a link um
come and say hello to me either through
Twitter
um you can message me through Twitter at
TV underscore Psy uh you can go on the
Facebook group and you can IM meets
Jamie Rickson
um or you can message me on here but
it's a little bit harder if you message
me here because I can't send you the
link directly but it happens to the
Discord you can
send me a message I can pass it on
Discord as well thank you sir I haven't
forgotten speaking of which give me a
second
what they're gonna put the link on okay
everybody just wait
wait I accidentally placed it twice but
it's fine
so yeah uh if you are new to the Channel
please like And subscribe and hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
you can also consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker hit the join button
um if you support the channel and you
want to show your love that's the best
way to do it
um and you can go to psychtrack.com for
merchandise as well and I will be added
to that if you've got any ideas for
designs I'm more than happy to steal
them
so that is the Discord server right
thank you for joining us I'm gonna go
watch the second half of the women's
football England against Spain
um I'm supporting the lionesses
so that's um
we're going to go and do that now I'm
gonna know what stranger things
so sweaty so thanks guys and
um if you see any more giant freaking
Stargate robots
just don't read it because the chances
are it's nonsense
at all them taking credit for everyone
else's hard work
and that's the bit that pisses me off
somebody said actually I've just gotta
leave you this quickly
um one of this um gate world people said
well should we do things should we I
think then I'm just talking about rumors
and lies and I'm like rumors don't
bother me if you say it's a rumor I talk
about rumors all the time but I will
tell you it's a rumor or I will tell you
where it's come from right
um this is a this is a subject I adore
I'm brave enough or sometimes stupid
enough to go out there and tell you
things that I've you know I'm not 100
whether true or not but I will tell you
if I'm not sure and you know and get the
information because I love talking about
this show because it's one of my
favorite shows ever you know
um gate world and people don't do that
if it's not 100 fact out there they they
don't they don't talk about it you know
um so that's fine that's the way they do
it more as a news channel
yeah exactly actual news so yeah yeah
yeah and their credibility is is really
important and now I'm more of a fan
Channel if you want to do a diff
different so um but what giant so yeah
so so that I I felt almost that they
were lumping me in the giant freaking
robot but they weren't they weren't but
the thing is the giant freaking robot
are doing that pissed me off is one
they're saying that what is a rumor is
fact and that annoys me
but taking credit for other people's
hard work really annoyed me and that is
the bit that's
that I will not forgive it's not just
you know
um a a fun story being like Oh that's a
bit of Soul I'm gonna start on that I
don't really believe it but our fun
story that's just
stupid and childish and Petty and that
annoyed me that made me angry
but if Liam Hemsworth's story is true
then I'll go on board back to be honest
I quite likely intense with I still
watched a movie with him last week you
know those movies I've dropping where
the um people hunt down a human being
for sport
I think it's called it's kind of what
it's called now something night
but anyway it's on Sky cinema at the
moment and I watched it last week it's
bloody brilliant between the executive
produced it as well it's really good
those films are normally [ __ ] but I was
reading but anyway
Matt Dean the Discord link is broken so
is it that's the one that we've got on
all our videos
ah dang it
uh two moments they last so long don't
they
uh no I I said I usually set them to
last forever
No Limit and expire never
but you'll figure it here we go here is
the new link
s
thanks Sebastian
I've got something I I I'll tell you a
way to fix it in a minute Joe
okay
right
yes and thank you and thank everybody
for joining this evening it's been
really really great
um please like I say like subscribe
share the video wherever the hell you
like
um over on the side track side Channel
I'll have a little Snippets from this
video over the next few days so you can
watch it in
bite size
cyber boy Matt bye-bye Matt
bye bye guys and as always whenever I
finish a video I have to go and try to
find the outro which I can never find
quickly enough
bye
[Music]